hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast experimental design best
practice for multi color flow cytometry
presented by carol oxford field
application scientist
Thermo Fisher Scientific I am Xavier get
a piece of libraries and I will be your
moderator for today's event today's
educational website Minar is brought to
you by lab roots and sponsored by thermo
Fisher Scientific for more information
on our sponsor please visit
www.dent.umich.edu/license as we have
time for at the end of the presentation
also please notice that you will be
viewing the presentation in the slide
window to enlarge the window click on
the arrows at the top right hand corner
of the slide window if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation click
on the support tab found at the top
right of the presentation window or
report your problem by clicking on the
answer question box located on the far
left of your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits
I'd like now I'd like to now introduce
our presenter miss Cara Oxford Cara
Oxford is currently field application
scientists with thermo Fisher Scientific
she has worked with slow Joe LLC and was
one of the founding partners of excite a
flow cytometry education company Miss
Oxford you may begin your presentation
thank you so much Xavier I really
appreciate the opportunity to come talk
to you about
flow cytometry I've done this for quite
some time
I was also the UC Davis flow cytometry
Corps director there for about 25 years
so I think flow cytometry is one of the
most elegant technologies in science
when I did flow cytometry
multi-parameter meant to solicit
fluorescent parameters and now the
people at the cutting edge of flow
cytometry are doing 32 fluorescent
parameters so it's changed quite a bit
during that time but I'm really thankful
to all of the mentors that I had and so
now I have a lot of experience and and
hope hopefully you'll find some
information here that's helpful to you
as you design your multi-parameter
panels I put my email address here on
the slide so that you can contact me
after the seminar if you want any
information that I give here you can
also email me about other topics in flow
cytometry
and I can give you some resources as
well in the seminar
so let's just talk about flow cytometry
in general there are advantages and
disadvantages of course to every
technology that we use in science and
there are a lot of advantages to flow
cytometry one of the things that I like
the most about this technology is that
we get a lot of information on a per
cell basis we use the populations of
cells that are that have a lot of
heterogeneity but we're doing this on a
per cell basis it's extremely
quantitative we look for statistics like
population frequency and expression
level on a large number of cells we can
look at tens of thousands or even
millions of cells in an extremely short
period of time and we can generate this
data very quickly
of course there are some limitations of
flow cytometry despite our best efforts
the cells must be in suspension and
those of us that have certainly run a
core facility or run our own data we
realize that putting clumps of cells or
putting pieces of tissue in a flow
cytometry quickly ends that experiment
and we spend a lot of time fighting with
the flow cytometry so we have to get the
cells in suspension we have to make sure
they're filtered or we use enzymes to
make sure that the cells pass through
the flow cytometry
the other limitations are we get no
spatial information unless we use a
complementary technology like microscopy
or an image stream which gives us
spatial information about where the
cells are to flow cytometry cells are an
electronic pulse we don't get any
information about where the fluorescence
is inside the cell
one thing that's
about flow cytometry data is it's very
easy to misunderstand the data and I get
this all the time from clients and
students who tell me that you know I've
had 30 years of experience so they want
me to look at their data or they want me
to analyze their data and what I want to
present today is that you don't have to
have 30 years of experience to get good
flow cytometry data this data is not
subjective it's very important to have
the adequate controls to understand a
little about physics and a little about
antibodies and to do a very careful
analysis people that are just starting
out in flow can do the analysis the same
way somebody that has 30 years of
experience it's just really important
and sometimes in fact most of the time
you'll have more controls than you will
have samples so it's just really
important to follow some important steps
to get really good flow data and we'll
talk about most of those here
so before you panic this slide is
extremely busy and it has a tremendous
amount of applications in flow I know
there were a lot of times in my career
that I thought well we're pretty well
done now we have a number of
applications but were kind of stuck and
then fluorescent proteins came to the
table and certain dyes came to the table
and probes came to the table and all of
a sudden we were off and running again
so I'm certainly not going to go over
any of these applications in particular
but I wanted to say that if we can
develop a fluorescent probe or a
fluorescent marker the list is almost
endless in the applications of flow
cytometry
but let's talk about flow cytometry best
practice these are the things we're
going to
about today they don't encompass all of
slow cytometry best practice but they're
certainly important to panel design the
first thing we're going to talk about is
how do we know the machine is performing
optimally certainly the manufacturer of
flow cytometry instrumentation is going
to develop a protocol to give you an
idea of whether the machine is
performing optimally and we're also
going to talk about what you might want
to do above and beyond this level of
testing to make sure you're get good
data we're also going to talk about how
to choose Laura force it's very
important to understand some of the
characteristics of fluorophores that
might make you choose one over the other
and give you an advantage in panel
design we're certainly going to talk
about titration this is one of the most
important and most simple concepts that
will give you good data and make panel
design much easier and then of course
getting along is important in the
workplace it's important in
relationships and it's incredibly
important in panel design not all
fluorochromes get along and we'll talk
about which ones do which ones don't and
how you can get them in a panel together
and then of course control issues me
well I didn't think I had control issues
but when you become an expert in
multicolor panel design you're going to
have to have control issues you're going
to run a lot of controls and you're
going to want to know what each one is
for and you're going to have a lot of
them so we talked about that already and
you're probably going to be sick of how
much I talk about them in this talk so
bear with me you'll still love flow
cytometry by the end of the talk I do
but we do have a lot of controls
so one of the most important things to
understand of course right and when
you're using any machine is what does it
do now I'm not going to get into the
heart of physics because I don't well I
shouldn't I don't like physics but I'm
not a physicist so I understand the
least I need to know about physics to
understand how the machine works so in
the top upper left corner of the slide
there you'll see what happens when you
open the machine would be a toon and XP
flow cytometry which I represent as the
field application scientist so here you
can see the filters of the machine and
you can see the lasers and some of the
optics so looks pretty complicated but
it all boils down to the detector what
is the Saitama tar doing it's counting
photons so we measure the photons that
are excited when the laser excites the
floor chrome and the floor chrome emits
photons the photons hit the photocathode
at the front of the PMT those photons or
I'm sorry the electrons that are now
knocked off that cathode go through a
diode cascade and they're amplified they
then are emitted off the other side of
the PMT and we can measure those with an
electronic pulse very very
straightforward so all you need to know
is that we quantify the photons we
measure the electronic pulse and there
you go if you know a little bit about
physics and a little bit about Photon
you're now a flow cytometry expert
so when we started in flow cytometry we
used analog instruments we didn't know a
lot about PMT's or at least I didn't and
we had a four-decade
scale to graph our data so we could walk
up to an instrument we could take an
unstained sample put it in that magic
place that we know is no longer magic
that first log decade on our scale we
knew that most of our fluorochromes most
of our samples would fit in that space
and maybe sometimes we had to turn the
voltage down but otherwise we got pretty
good data then we started using analog
to digital hybrid machines and then
fully digital instruments and we saw all
sorts of things happening we saw that if
we crank the voltage up there were
populations appearing that we didn't see
before
and we saw our background increase
sometimes we solve for two things so we
realize that we needed to understand a
lot more about PMT's we needed to set
voltages that were appropriate for our
experiments so we needed to do some
optimization that's now been called
either a voltage walk or a volt raishin
filtration sounds really cool if you
print it on a t-shirt it makes you very
popular at parties
I'm just kidding yes I also find my
jokes really humorous so what does a
volte raishin do it assures the best
signal-to-noise detection which is what
we want to do our data is important to
know the difference between background
and negative and positive we also want
to sure all the measurements are being
made in the literary linear range of the
detector so before when we only had four
decades and now we have instruments with
five decades six decades and seven
decades of range so we need to know how
many decades of real data we get from
the electronics so decreasing the
voltage below the minimum voltage that
we find in a bill tration the resolution
of dim populations may be lost
increasing the voltage for a given PMT
above this voltage gives no advantage in
population resolution so I get a
question all the time also from
customers why not just put a sample on
and increase the voltage until the
positive is almost off scale which is
really what we first did if a low
voltage is a problem because we're
detecting the noise of the instrument
why not just crank the voltage up well
then we realized that that instrument
noise can also become a problem and we
get spillover spreading from the machine
so I'll explain this as well
so this is one way to do a voltage
optimization so we used here our ultra
comp beads and I'll talk about those in
a minute but basically they're antibody
capture beads and they contain a binding
bead and a non binding bead these beads
bind to the variable region of your
antibody so you can put your antibody in
the tube put the beads in the tube and
they have two populations they bind to
the variable region so here you can see
at the PMT voltage of 1 volt which is
basically off we haven't applied enough
voltage to the PMT to get a signal and
here you can look that there's basically
only one population both of those beads
are not being excited enough to see and
we start walking the voltage up very
straight forward and as we get two
populations to appear and then the beads
start to go off scale we lower that
voltage difference to about 25 volts and
this is the detector here if you can't
see the slides very well the detector is
the bl1 detector on the attune and that
is excited by the blue laser and it
emits in the emission filter there is
five thirty thirty so we're collecting
green excitation off a blue laser
so if we do what's called a
concatenation in flo-jo you can look
here and see some interesting things
about the data you can see that down at
the low end at 250 and 300 volts
the data is not linear you can see the
data starts to become linear when we hit
350 volts so we know we want to be above
that range you can also see that maybe
somewhere around 375 volts that
background starts to spread that's going
to become a huge issue when we start
using multicolor panels so here how
would we decide what voltage to use well
I can pick a magic red arrow there and I
can tell you that's what voltage I've
picked and I'll tell you why in a minute
so here's a voltage optimisation that's
been done on a tuned NXT and I've picked
or I've walked five PMT's off our blue
laser three off the red and three off
the violet now you can do this on your
machine as well you walk each PMT
individually and this is what you get
when you visualize the concatenation and
flo-jo
so what in the world do you do with all
that data well there's a number of
things you can do so what we did and we
published or we submit an abstract at
Saito and I can certainly send that to
you if you want it will also be
published in our bio probes and I can
send you the link to that as well on our
website so here is the data looking at
again that Beall 1 PMT and also the
while for PMT the wild for PMT is yellow
excitation and the channel that you
would sorry I don't know the filter
there I can that's the excitation of psi
7 so that's long red emission off the
yellow laser so we looked at several
metrics here the stain index which I'll
explain in a minute give you the formula
for that you can google Marty B ghost
and stain index for the publication on
that we also looked at separation index
we looked at robust CV of the positive
signal we also looked at two times the
standard deviation of the negative
signal there are a lot of metrics you
can look at here basically what you want
to see is you can look at where the
robust VV starts to decline and flatten
out and then you can also look at where
the peak of the stain index is and where
that starts to flatten out so here for
is a wild for PMT for example that
starts to happen at about 400
so there are these are some various
methods and metrics you can look at for
the voltage optimisation so if you look
at these graphs you can certainly argue
that there are several voltages that
might work and that's a valid argument
the next step in this process is to take
your data run them at voltages here a
minimum voltage say 400 375 425 and see
how this affects your data look at some
data with low expressing markers and see
if it makes a difference the real point
of this optimization is to find a
minimum baseline voltage you may adjust
those voltages up or down but probably
not this is a good place to start every
experiment
here's another option for your voltage
optimization here you have a hard dye
bead the bead that I use for this
optimization is the peak to of the zero
tech eight peak bead set this is a hard
dyed bead it is a single peak so I don't
have two peaks here that I have to set a
gate on and I did some very simple
metrics
I used the robust CV and the robust
standard deviation and I looked at those
graphs simply in Excel and I looked at
the range I didn't look at the
inflection point that's also an
interesting point but I looked basically
at the robust CV where that leveled off
and I looked at where the robust
standard deviation started to rise so
for example for this PMT I would
probably pick a voltage of about 350 for
my minimum baseline voltage and the
reason I would pick that voltage is I
get a good flat CV so I know increasing
the voltage there would not give me an
advantage and I have a very low
contribution of the electronic noise
measured by the standard deviation I've
done this on several occasions on
multiple occasions with multiple
machines I've also run data here and
that suggests that I get a very good
signal and I also get a good data here
so
I all the next step that I do in this
optimization because I take another hard
dyed bead for example the peak 5 bead
and I walk my instrument for all PMT's
doing this optimization when I find
those voltages I make a histogram with
all of my PMT's
then I run the voltages from the
optimization and I run my slightly
brighter bead my peak 5 bead at all of
these voltage voltages and I set a gate
and I run this every day and I use the
voltages every day for my experiments
that way if my instrument changes if
anything changes in my experiment I can
say to the FDA or to the reviewer of a
paper that I have measured the same
fluorescence every day so this is a
great way to not only make sure that
your instrument is characterized but
make sure that you are characterizing
your experiment as well
so let's review the voltage optimization
we want to optimize our PMT voltages so
we have a minimum voltage where we are
always detecting a voltage or detecting
our cells and our signal above
background
if we do need to go below this minimum
and why would that ever happen if I put
on my cells and I realized that now my
positive signal is off scale if I
haven't titrated or maybe I'm using GFP
and I just can't get that signal on
scale it's the most important that you
have to get it on scale so you're going
to lower your voltage if I have to do
that I know that I may be sacrificing
signal-to-noise but at least I have an
understanding of that and with GFP if
I'm only looking at something bright
signal-to-noise may not be my most
important consideration if I raise the
voltage there's no advantage to
resolution
want to change these just for resolution
and optimization is very important so
just get it done
if I do this on at a tune NXT with the
hard dye beads it takes me about an hour
I throw the numbers into Excel and it's
very easy
okay so now we have our flow cytometry
what's next
so there are many ways to do panel
design there's an excellent paper by
Yolanda manky and Mario Roederer I
believe it's from 2010 but if you search
panel design and those two names ma n ke
and ro e de AR ER you can find the paper
and it talks about ranking your markers
you want to choose the markers which
best answer your research question they
mark them or I'm sorry they rank them
the primary secondary and tertiary I
find that very helpful it's not engraved
in stone but it's very helpful because
again I use this little rhyme the more
colors you use the more sensitivity you
lose it's counterintuitive but the more
fluorochromes you add to a panel you
encounter a concept called background
expansion because of spillover spreading
and this is a problem of physics not
something that compensation corrects or
not something we can avoid so if you can
answer the question with less markers
it's always an advantage to do so but of
course nobody wants to do that right we
want to use more markers so we'll talk
about how to do that
you're going to want to titrate all your
reagents you're going to want to screen
for the best ones what are the best ones
well of course they're the ones that
separate the population best but also
sometimes the same reagent conjugated to
a different flora Chrome is going to
give you a different staining pattern so
you want to test all the combinations
that you can you want to troubleshoot
four-inch issues with sensitivity I'll
give you some tips there and then you
generate your data
of course this goes back to high school
science right or maybe even elementary
school science we determine a biological
hypothesis which antibodies do we need
for markers of interest you're going to
do a literature search and there's a
really helpful source that you can do
this they're called omote talk about
that in a minute and show you where you
can find them but the most important
thing is that panel design is iterative
predicted panels are exactly that
they're predicted
panels and no matter how much expertise
you have I can give you a predicted
panel but I can't tell you if it's going
to work or not with any confidence I
used to teach week-long courses in flow
cytometry and every single class there'd
be people disappointed at the end that I
couldn't hand them a panel that worked I
certainly can hand you panels that I've
done I can give you panels in the
literature that other people have done
but they have a successful chance of
working but you are not going to do well
unless you want to repeat their work
you're not going to do the same thing on
the same machine with the same cells so
you're certainly going to have to do
this in an iterative manner the idea is
that you're going to do a backbone panel
that always works and then you're going
to add antibodies and add markers and
see if that backbone works until you can
add as many markers as you need
but there is a lot of help out there the
flow cytometry community is really
really collaborative and boom it's were
designed or actually introduced by the
reviewers of the journal cytometry so I
think there are more than 50 now these
are open source and they were designed
because no matter where you publish a
paper you can never get all the
information that you need from the
journals methods section so let's say I
want to publish a paper in nature
Carol's cool t-cells kill cancer so
unfortunately you can never get all of
the important details out of the
materials and methods section so I can
get another paper a two page paper
called an omit optimized multicolor
Amina phenotyping panel and I can get
that from or I can publish that in
cytometry
so this gives all of the detail that
flow cytometry nerds want to see right
you can see important things like the
gating strategy the clones the panel
design did I have any difficulty with
certain antibody combinations here you
can see in the gating strategy I don't
use a forwards and side scatter gate to
determine any of my cells of interest I
just use it as a debris elimination gate
a gate first on my doublet i gate second
on my dump channel and viability die I
use different types of plots I use maybe
a plot that shows me some back gating
that I did so it's really really
critical but that you can use these as a
reference we also keep track of these on
our website you can look at our flow
cytometry resource library which has a
tremendous number of resources for both
people that are new to flow cytometry
and people that are very experienced we
have flow cytometry application notes
techniques we have videos so that if you
are new to flow cytometry you can figure
out how full photometer works but we
also keep track of all the Oh Maps here
and so that because if you google them
sometimes only a few of them come up I
really appreciate them because
when I studied t-cells they were just
activated or producing cytokines now
people ask me about panels for t-cell
exhaustion well they weren't exhausted
when I was studying them you guys have
the hard work to do right field
people in the field we did the easy work
so these will really help you with your
with your research
I talked about the stain index this is
the formula for stain index basically
the median of the positive minus the
median of the negative over two times
the standard deviation it's a metric
that allows us to look at the separation
of our populations there are many of
them out there but this is one that we
would commonly use so antibody titration
people always ask me what's the best way
to titrate an antibody anyway you want
to write her a tremendous amount of
protocols out there for this one of them
but I like is by Ryan Duggan if you
google Ryan Duggan and titration and
alexa 488 he has a great protocol that
actually tells you the amount of PBS to
put in a well when you're titrating your
antibodies this is a titration that was
done by one of our scientists it looks
at serial dilutions of a 1 to 2
concentration of antibody and then the
graphing of the stain index so this is
where there's a lot of Mythology about
antibody concentration so here's the
graph of a stain index that you can see
and when I was new to flow I would have
said well I would I would look at this
and pick one of the higher
concentrations of antibody where that
stain index flattens out because I want
to be at saturation which might be the
concentration here
but then now I've learned that you can
use a concentration here there's a
difference between a saturating tighter
and a staining tighter the one thing
you're trying to do here or maybe you're
trying to do is to make sure that in the
population that you're trying to detect
you're detecting the percent positive
now if you're trying to see the
population shift or the MFI shift you're
going to want to use the saturation
titer that's a different case but most
of us are just trying to say I have
twenty percent of these or fifty percent
of those so in that case you may want to
use a saturate income or a separating
concentration the saturating
concentration if you increase the
antibody you only increase the
nonspecific background people always ask
me well why can't you just wash more
washing does not eliminate nonspecific
background at least it doesn't very well
washing is a great way to lose cells you
usually lose about half of them in every
wash
it does eliminate excess flora Chrome
but that's really not the important
thing that you want to do when you're
titrating and staining
separating concentration gives you good
separation of your cells
it reduces your spreading error and it
saves you antibody so you can often use
the separating concentration when you're
only looking at the percent positives
which is really what the vast majority
of us do when we're doing Amina
phenotyping
let's talk a bit about spillover
compensation and spread these terms are
thrown around a lot in flow cytometry
there's sort of the language that
flowers speak you'll also hear the term
spillover spreading bear with me a
minute as I talk about something that's
not on the slide here when I talk about
compensation I often use fitzy because
it's a Splore crumb that we're all
really familiar with and when I ask what
color is fitzy you say green well I just
set you up for failure right because
it's a trick question
gypsy is not green we think fitzy is
green because we've been scammed kid C
is green or we think it's green because
we look at it under a microscope and we
have a filter on that microscope that
only allows those really energetic green
photons back to our eye so
truth about fitzy feel like making a
Netflix documentary the truth about
fitzy is that if we didn't have that
filter the emission spectra and here
you'll see the emission spectra of PE
sigh five point five on your screen I'm
sorry maybe it's Percy psi five point
five yes it is so an emission spectra is
a probability curve so going back to
fitzy if I hit fitzy with a blue laser
the the chances of fitzy or the
probability of fitzy
omitting green photons is very very high
but fitzy also has a very good
probability of emitting yellow photons
or orange photons or even red photons
and I have a flow cytometry that very
well detect yellow orange and red
photons so but it's very easy for me to
determine where those photons are coming
from if I have a single stain for every
color that I use in my experiment
so we now use compensation which is an
algorithm to separate these the emission
of these fluorochromes and visualize
them in multi-dimensional space and that
sounds really tricky and the math might
be too complicated for me to do in my
head but it's very very easy in
practicality so here is two floor
Chrome's
that we use per C psi 5.5 and a PC Alexa
700 and here's the example of where the
photons are that are emitted by one and
detected in a neighboring PMT
so when I use a single stain Percy piece
i 5.5 sample
the cells or all of the beads whichever
this is
detected in the detector the primary
detector where I want to make a
measurement they're also detected in
this secondary detector where I'm going
to eventually make another measurement
and this cell gets a number here and it
also gets a value in this detector so
compensation just uses an algorithm to
force the median of this value on the
y-axis
to be the median to be equivalent to the
median of this on this axis as well we
could have chosen another algorithm to
do this but we chose compensation till
compensation allows us to visualize the
effects of spillover in
multi-dimensional space sounds
complicated it's not it just uses a
vector and the slope of this line to do
the calculation so here we have a median
of twelve hundred and seventy seven and
sixty point two I'm sorry we have an MFI
here in this on this axis
compensation and our single stain sample
to adjust these medians to be more
equivalent and we have a fully
compensated sample now when this cell
gets a value here and this cell gets a
value here I can't change that value I
can only bring it down to lower into the
log scale and now I visualize this
spread it's not visible on this because
it's not visible here sorry because it's
on the high end of log space it's much
more visible here this is what is called
spread or spillover spread don't really
like those terms but we're kind of stuck
with them so that's what you see here
so this is an important example looking
at uncompensated and compensated data
usually we can recognize that the plot
on the left is uncompensated by the
strange diagonal
on the right we only know the data is
compensated because it's marked
uncompensated we really don't have any
way to statistically determine that
those medians are equivalent in the
compensation controls it's important to
know that we've used the right
compensation controlled and we don't
know on the left that the population
that is dimly stained for CD 11 B and
brightly stained for C 11 C is indeed
double positive so we want to make sure
and use the right compensation controls
to make sure we have good data
sensation is very easy even though the
mask is kind of complex
so compensation beads are really the
easiest way to do compensation they work
for all lasers and depending on the
manufacturer they work for every
antibody the beads that we carry the
eBay Oh ultra can't be work for mouse
rat or hamster the ABC beads also work
for rabbit antibodies
the thing that our is it features that
are nice about the beads the unstained
bead fluorescence is very similar to
most so and they give you a bright stain
and a clear separation so the rules of
compensation of course are that you have
to have a single stain for each floor in
your sample or in your panel you need to
have a negative positive either in the
tube or in the algorithm so you can use
an unstained
it used to be important that you had the
sample as bright or brighter but when
I've talked to experts in the field like
they've parked who writes the
compensation algorithms in the software
he said the algorithm should calculate
that math for you I think it's still
probably important to have a very bright
and well separated population and the
beads do this for you
certainly if the target is not highly
expressed on your cells or expressed by
only a few cells so for example if
you're using a cytokine or Fox p3 or
something that's not well expressed
these compensation beads work really
really well
so now that we've got our compensation
controls done our instrument voltages
are set we want to talk about some basic
strategy for fluorochromes selection
so we wanted to save the brightest
fluorochromes for our dhimmis markers
so how do we know that our markers are
dim or bright or are fluorochromes or
dimmer bright I'll talk about that on
the next slide we want to save our
important targets which we ranked with
the paper that I discussed so we want to
save these for the brightest lower
Chrome's
AP CPE Alexa dies super brights these
are the worst resolved they have low
expression or poor antigen access or
they have an unknown expression level if
I want to look at antigen X I may not
know what the expression level is then I
want to minimize the spillover I think
about this as part a and Part B of panel
design I like to have a spillover
spreading chart that's Part B and then I
like to have a stain index chart that's
part a so I want to look at stain index
and spillover spreading so let's go to
the stain index slide
you
here's an example of the ranking of
fluorochromes by stain index
one that we did at thermo Fisher we took
it freshly isolated PBMCs and stained
them with anti human cd4 conjugated to
various fluorochromes now this of course
will vary manufacturer to manufacturer
it will vary instrument to instrument to
what we've listed here is the flora
chrome the laser the filter and the
stain index that we got with the attune
and xt+ sight ometer you can certainly
use this on your instrument these things
will be relative instrument to
instrument it is best to use it on your
instrument and certainly different
manufacturers will have this for their
instruments in their fluorochromes I
like to have this print out in front of
me so I can see the brightness of work
force
also depends on several things
fluorophores are bright because their
quantum efficient for example fitzy is a
very quantum efficient when you hit
fitzy with a lot of light you get a lot
of photons
fitzy unfortunately is can be a problem
if you're looking at an auto fluorescent
cell line because you also have of
course auto fluorescent and auto
fluorescence protein Auto fluorescent
proteins emit in the green so the
brightness of this only accounts for the
stain index and not necessarily for the
autofluorescence that's another thing
you want to consider but this is a great
chart to have as you're doing panel
design
so here we'll start out talking about
spillover spreading so we talked a
little bit about looking at
fluorochromes that have emission spectra
that overlap so on the Left you'll see
an example of CD 3 APC alexa fluor 780
and CD 56 APC you can see that those
emission spectra overlapped a bit and if
you use these on cells that are Co
expressing the same markers you can
certainly see that the pattern that you
get even if you used an FM oh it'd be
very difficult to see
how to quantitate those populations if
we separate those co-expressed markers
onto floors like a floor 450 and a PC we
can see a much better staining pattern
that gives us a much better idea of how
those cells are co-expressed
and this is a classic example of two
floor Chrome's that are used quite often
in panel design
so here's an example
pe into Percy psi 5.5 PE is a very very
bright dye and it's often that
manufacturers when they come out with a
new antibody the first thing they do is
conjugate it to PE and I'll tell you
that PE is possibly the worst place to
make a sensitive measurement in your
sight ometer now PE is very bright we
use it all the time but it PE is also
the place that accepts the a lot of
error from the other fluorochromes that
you use on your site ometer and I'll
show you why
so here we have a PE single stain and
we're measuring that in PE and in Percy
psi 5.5 so again as each cell goes
through the site ometer it gets a value
in every detector
we
compensate that data you can see the
spread of this data so compensation lets
us visualize the spillover and the
spread so if we used a gate on the
unstained population obviously it looks
like there's a population of double
stained cells on the right those aren't
double stained we can certainly see that
we would have to use an FM oh but these
cells are definitely there so there's an
easy way to do this in multi color space
this is a neat trick so here instead of
thinking about how bright our stain is
right which is part one of panel design
the stain index now we're going to think
about if we have to have for that Nobel
Prize or that paper in nature we have to
have a Percy psi 5.5 or a fitzy antibody
and here's the fitzy antibody I
absolutely have to have and here I'm
looking at that antibody in fitzy and in
Percy psi 5.5
now I add more antibodies to this panel
I've added that the two antibodies that
I cannot live without and I've added a
PC size 7 BV for 21 psi 7 and the other
antibody that I have to have in my panel
now with all of these dyes in the panel
I can still use what the two antibodies
I need without any problem you can see
the background expands a bit from
spreading up the other floors but no
matter where I set a gate I can easily
determine the population percentage of
those two dyes now I add PE BB 605 and
BB 7/11
now I have a problem
two antibodies on using the 50 and the
Percy piece i 5.5 if the staining is as
bright as it looks here they're not a
problem but if the staining is dim now I
have fluorescence all the way out to the
third log in the percy piece i 5.5
channel the fitzy channel is virtually
uneffective it is one of those dyes that
plays nicely with others it does not
accept error from any of these dyes
certainly
the per CP by 5.5 channel there is
background expansion and right now all I
know is that it's from PE or BB 605 or
BB 711 now certainly the more experience
you get with panel design you'll know
where it's coming from
little trick can tell you exactly where
it's coming from so here I can look at
every single stain sample and I can look
at it in my 50 channel and like we saw
before all of these single stain samples
look fine when we detect them in the 50
detector
now when we look at all of the dyes
single stained and contaminated and
flo-jo we can see exactly where the
problem is PE and BD 7/11 when I add
these two dyes they contribute quite a
bit of a background expansion to the
Percy psi 5x5 channel so I know that if
I'm going to use an antibody in Percy
psi 5.5 it has to be brighter then that
10 to the 3 point because if it's dimmer
than that I just won't see it in multi
color space unless I use it on different
cells then I'm staining with the PE and
the BB 7 11 and our new super bright
dyes that also emit off the violet
channel would have the same
characteristics because they have the
same emission or very similar emission
spectra
example are all the same dyes in the BB
7-eleven detector so you can see Percy
psi 5.5 is going to be causing some
background issues for BB 7/11 and here
you can see all the dyes that cause
background issues in P sy 7 again PE 7
is very bright and often used in
multicolor panels but you can see it's
not a place that you would necessarily
want to make a dim measurement so these
are very important measurements to make
and understand which dies cause
contributions and which dyes you might
want to either keep separate or save for
your brightest markers
let's just do a quick spreading error
review these are basically caused by
photon counting statistics
like to think of photons like kids
basically we really like energetic kids
we like blue green violet photons they
have tremendous amount of energy when
they hit that cathode and knock off lots
of electrons and as scientist we like
ends of lot of numbers right we can
count those we get great statistics we
get very low variation and unfortunately
the red photons are like teenagers I
love my children I raise them through
their teenage years but they're a very
bad investment you put lots of energy in
you never get that energy back right
there's lost your rotation translation
heat energy and when they knock off
electrons sometimes they knock off a
little sometimes they knock off a lot
and when we count them there's just this
spread right we can still use them there
are advantages to using them but we need
to understand that we get the spreading
error and there is a way to predict it
and there's a way to use them wisely
so here's an example of a great paper in
Mario motorers group and this is a
calculation of some spillover spreading
matrices now this is another paper that
is very complicated and if you have to
do the math by hand I don't envy you how
we used to do this on all of our
machines in the lab and it took a lot of
time but it's very valuable data here
you can see where these fluorochromes
don't get along and where you're going
to have issues these are on LS are two
instruments and looking at Q dots and
some of the other fluorochromes
example of a spillover spreading matrix
that I generated in flo-jo with some of
the scientists at thermo Fisher so this
is a very easy thing to do in flo-jo
so you take the data of single stain
these are cd4 on an attune and XT v6
configuration and these numbers give you
some warning signs based on the red
color so for example this is v l5 and RL
two on the attune MXT
this is super-bright 702 and
Alexis 700 so these emit in the same
channel off of different lasers and
sorry they have that a similar
excitation spectra to different lasers
so you can see where they might have an
issue and so this is just a little bit
of a warning to say that you're going to
have to be careful if you use these two
together on the same cells so this is
really helpful you can do it easily with
single stain cells this is with c4 a
super-bright dies and several different
fluorophores on a to NXT
so this is really helpful and very easy
to do you can do this for your machine
it doesn't take long just run the single
stains throw it in flo-jo and here's a
button you click on for the spillover
spreading matrix
and we'll talk a little bit very quickly
about staining controls this is in the
literature and there's a lot of great
articles here so I won't go too heavily
on them but there's some very important
controls that you need to do when you're
doing multicolor flow cytometry and the
number one control that I find people
are not using as much as they probably
should our fluorescence - one controls
these controls are not compensation
controls they're dating controls and
then we'll talk a little bit about the
rest of the ones on the list here
the fluorescence minus one controls
pain at all of the markers except the
one of interest so if I want to do a
fitzy FMO control to determine what's
positive and negative 4/5 C I want to
use all the other fluorochromes in my
panel except for fitzy they help us
control for the effective spread they
allow delineation of positive from
negative and they're important for low
density or smeared populations
here's a couple of examples of how
fluorescence - one control is used in
gating for flow cytometry you can see on
the left in both cases
we've set a gate on the unstained and on
the right you can certainly see that
that gate is not appropriate for the
full stain
and you want to move the gate up but you
certainly can't convince a reviewer that
Carol said I could move the gate up
unfortunately that doesn't get a paper
into a journal I wish it did but if you
run the FMO you can see that that gate
definitely defines the population and
describes that spillover spread that we
see they're setting gates is not
arbitrary and I can certainly not set
gates any better with 30 years of
experience than you can I use the proper
controls as well don't want to rely on
the unstained
and certainly people ask what how many
FMOs do I need to run for every
experiment so what I do is if I'm doing
a 14 color experiment I'm going to do 14
fmos with that first experiment and here
for example in the first
panel of plots that you see the PSI 7
and the cd45 PSI 5.5 I would not need to
use those two fmos after the first time
I run them because no matter where I set
those gates I can get a good read on the
separation between those two populations
once I've set the FMO and I realized
where I need to set it
I can tell a reviewer I ran these FMOs
the first time I got good separation and
I didn't have to run them the next time
in the bottom two panels I probably
would not need to use the cd8 FMO but I
would certainly need to use the FMO for
PE because they're the the antigen is
expressed on a continuum and I would
really need to set that FMO every time
because moving that gate very slightly
in either direction is going to change
the value significantly and here again
also I probably wouldn't even use
quadrants for this gate I would probably
set them as squares because quadrants
really don't describe flow data very
well
so here again you have controls based on
what you're going to do to your cells if
you make changes or if you treat cells
with radiation or you stimulate them or
you kill them or there's something that
you do to your cells that create a
change in yourself there may be changes
that affect your fluorescence that
affect your scatter that effect the
stickiness so you want to do as many
controls as you can especially in the
beginning of an experiment that you so
that you can see any of these changes
that might occur
type controls are very controversial in
flow they're not often used anymore
there's a tremendous amount of
literature out there on them if you have
to use an ISO type control you want to
throw it into your FMO at the titration
that you use your antibody and really
the only thing that an ice ax type shows
you is that you have a titration issue
it shows you that you have a nonspecific
binding problem so it's really something
that you might want to consider only
using in your FML control
viability it's very important to
eliminate unwanted sell dead cells are
sticky it's very important to use a
viability control in every sample dump
channel not necessary but often very
helpful you can eliminate unwanted cells
from analysis this is being very helpful
in things like stem cell analysis stem
cells are very rare we want to make sure
we look at undifferentiated cells you
can add differentiation markers all in
the same channel you can use them in the
same channel as your viability dye and
get them out
that shows the Eman reactive dyes for
dead cell identification we have eight
different options at thermo Fisher these
are great we used to use EMA which
required ultraviolet light fixation and
when these came out these are fantastic
live cells have some a means dead cells
have many more so you can take these
dyes lock them into a place in your
panel where you don't have another
reagent get them out we have ABC aming
reactive compensation beads so they're
really fantastic for use in your panel
we also have a number of impermanent
nucleic acid dyes for dead cell
identification these are very bright
come in a number of colors that you can
also slot into your panel these are for
use for live cells the others can be
also the aming reactors eyes can also be
used in live cells or in fixed cells
so here's an example of the importance
of using a viability indicator so
forward and scatter forward side scatter
we know are not to be used for dead cell
indications because they really don't
are not a good indicator of viability if
you get here on the upper left panel and
you see a forward and side scatter date
this is a using log side scatter as the
perfetto and hurt Sandburg and rubber
lab often do you can see here that the
live cells and dead cells that are
determined by scatter if you get them
separately you'll get a very very
different phenotype and you'll still
have dead cells in the final analysis
that look like CD 107 positive cells and
so it's very important that you get them
out in the beginning using a dead cell
indicator
here's a slide just looking at the
differences that you'll get when you
exclude dead cells when you use a dump
channel and when you exclude doublets so
if you're looking at rare cells or if
you're looking at any cells it's really
important to exclude the cells that you
need to exclude in flow cytometry
in summary know your instrument know the
configuration know what your performance
test that's determined by your
manufacturer know what the results give
you and how your instruments performing
do a voltage optimization
no your fluorophores no their brightness
look at a stand index look at your
compensation and you're still Oh or
spreading
titrate very important then when you put
the panel together look at the spillover
spreading the antigen density and then
always always be a control freak
use your controls for gating
so I'll leave you with a slide with lots
of educational resources I think it's
very important to have mentors and to
have web resources believe it or not I
did most of my flow before there was a
web but now we have tremendous resources
on the web we have guided learning you
can use our school of fluorescence lab
routes of course we have archived
webinars that you can use that are some
are very basic some are very advanced we
have an invitation
flow cytometry panel builder that you
can look at what reagents to choose for
your panels Learning Centres
publications friends don't let friends
do flow cytometry alone so I appreciate
your attention thank you very much and
if you have any questions please let me
know
thank you Miss Oxford for your
informative presentation we will now
start the Q&A portion of the webinar and
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on that ask
a question box located on the far left
of your screen well answer as many
questions as we have time for our first
question is you mentioned there are a
variety of methods for optimization what
are the other methods used and do you
have a recommendation
question we've been going back about
those methods for our back-and-forth
about those methods for cash probably 20
years now we just did a study at thermo
Fisher and published a poster about that
and I can certainly email any
participants that would like that there
are probably also talks about this from
the icepack website International
Society for the Advancement of cytometry
my favorite method is the easy one but
of course I want to get good data too so
I think the peek 2 method is the one I
like uses a single bead looking at the
standard deviation in the CV but there
are a lot of methods out there there are
methods that are published by the group
at Martin Mario rotaries lab so if you
want to take a deep dive certainly simon
mo nard did some talks on this and has
published this as well mo na Rd there's
a lot of data out there but I think my
personal favorite is the is the peak
tube method the antibody capture beading
method is good as well it just takes a
little bit more number crunching
and what is the difference between
compensation spillover and spillover
spreading
that's a very good question so I really
don't like the terms of spillover sort
of makes you think that there's so much
fluorescence that spills over from one
channel into the next and it's really
not it's like I spoke about with fitzy
you're really detecting the photons of
one
a chrome in the neighboring detector so
spillover is exactly that you're
detecting the photons of one flora
chrome in an adjacent PMT or doesn't
even have to be adjacent you're just
detecting the photons of one fluorophore
in a detector where you're going to make
another measurement
spreading is caused by photon counting
error that's just caused because of the
nature of of photons if they have low
energy like teenagers then they have a
lot of spreading it's just physics and
compensation helps us visualize
that's spreading but it doesn't fix it
until we get you know new PMT's that are
better detecting these photons there's
just no way around it other than good
panel design
and we're going to have time for one
more question
I don't have flo-jo is there any way is
there any other way to generate a
spreading matrix
sure yeah you can actually use the
papers there's two papers actually the
one that I gave in the lecture is
certainly available the math in that
paper is a little more complicated than
I like to do by hand there is also a
paper I'm going to try and remember it
off the top of my head it's also a Mario
rotor or paper and a Marty bigos paper
I think it's called unraveling the
immune system 17 color flow cytometry
and it has a bit of an easier math
equation that looks at the spreading and
you can use that equation to generate a
matrix by hand we certainly did that
before
Clojure was able to do the math so yeah
you can do a matrix or you can even take
the matrix in either one of those papers
and use it as a general guide certainly
the value of those numbers will change
instrument to instrument but the
relationship between the fluorophores is
not going to change so you can look at
the ones that are an issue on any
machine and they're going to be an issue
on every machine they may be more or
less of an issue but they're still going
to be ones that you're going to want to
know are going to be a problem and
design your panel to begin with
knowing that that is going to be an
issue
well Alexa once again thickness officers
for her presentation and before we go I
would like to thank the audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions questions we did
not have time for today will be
addressed by the speaker via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration we would like to thank lab
roots and our sponsor Thermo Fisher
Scientific for underwriting today's
educational webcast this webcast can be
viewed on-demand through April 2019 lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
event until next time goodbye